Well I marched through the storm, and I marched
through the rain.
And I marched through some sickness and some
heartache and pain.
And I laid on the ground, and I looked up
at the sky,
and I prayed to Lord up above and asked why.
But oh no, I'm not tired, I'm not through
marching yet,
and I'ma march until I die, oh children: this
you can bet.
So we say I'm gonna sing out, I'm gonna march on.
I'm gonna sing out, I'm gonna march on.
Gonna put one foot in front of the other foot yes I am
Oh, well my grandmomma marched, and
my granddaddy too.
And I never thought it'd be something that
I'd have to do.
But I'll march if I must.
I got a mission, you see.
And I'll be damned if my children have to
march for me.
Now, I believe in the power of raising my
voice.
And I believe in the power of making some
noise.
If I die I can't sing, and if I can't sing
I'll die.
So we should sing for one another now let's give it a try.
I'm gonna sing out, I'm gonna march on.
(repeats)
[Applause]
John Lewis
An extraordinary honor for both the students and John Lewis himself
What a beautiful, beautiful tribute to him
I was only 18 when I heard him at the March on Washington